it is time for this week's pet project
amy lee
joins us from the nspca she brought
along someone who needs a safe and good
home how are you doing amy
i think thanks for watching good it's
good to see you and you've got
malibu with you and to help you out with
malibu you've got isaiah helping out
today
yeah malcolm was a fantastic girl she's
just a little bit of a wiggle worm so i
just needed a little help
kind of holding her she's she you know
she wants her treats obviously um
malibu is such an awesome girl and i
do not know why we can't find her home
yet but i know somebody's out there for
her
she is a beautiful six-year-old girl let
me bring her over here
she's a beautiful six-year-old girl
she's active she weighs about 40 pounds
um and we just want to find her a home
where she can go on hikes
with her new family where she'll go on
walks every day
and we'll stay active she's playful
she's well behaved
um when we take her out obviously right
now she doesn't i think she's camera shy
you mentioned as we were talking
beforehand that she's part border collie
i have a border collie
and i can attest these are active dogs
they're the sweetest dogs on the earth
but they are active they need to get
exercise they need to play a lot
you nailed it i mean this is that this
is that girl i mean she wants a yard she
wants to play she wants to
just be entertained and she's like i
said she's a very very intelligent girl
um about she weighs about 40 pounds and
you know i think with the family
uh you know kids eight plus she'd be
fantastic um
she's great you just want to find her at
home with somebody that wants to take
her on hikes and go
she's a love bug she loves isaiah that's
for sure
so people can people can do a virtual
meet and greet nowadays right
that you got yep so what you're gonna do
is you actually book an appointment
um online on our website at
nevadaspca.org
and we'll you'll be able to speak with
an adoption counselor and they'll go
really
really in depth with you um as far as
malibu's needs which really you know
if you've got uh you know an active
household you know and you're willing to
give her love and care that she needs i
mean
that's really what we're looking for for
malibu she's definitely a sweetheart amy
thank you so much malibu isaiah thank
you too
if you're interested in adopting a pet
go to nevadaspca.org or call them at
that phone number 702-873-7722
rocky